so earlier this week republicans dragged
sally yates into a senate hearing to
investigate their continued conspiracy
theories about the michael flynn
investigation
and it went so poorly for them remember
that sally yates is the former deputy
attorney general she's criticized
the justice department's decision to
drop the prosecution against michael
flynn who is
as a reminder the former trump national
security adviser who had been
indicted so republicans have cooked up
all sorts of different conspiracy
theories many of which go through
sally yates and republicans control the
senate at least until january they
brought
sally yates in to testify via video
conference and it just went
so poorly for republicans i want to show
you a few clips
now she testified about how the obama
white house
first became alarmed about michael
flynn's behavior
that flynn was having secret discussions
with the russian ambassador before being
sworn in
he was talking to mike pence about
things that
really stunk to high heaven so yates
explains that
it was investigated plain and simple
there was really no
scandal there but of course republicans
have been
desperate and continue to be desperate
to claim that there was an obama
administration conspiracy to take down
trump
that includes the obama administration
illegally
spying on the trump campaign all of this
different stuff they want to claim that
it was investigative of abuse and much
more
but take a look at how badly this
imploded in their faces
sally yates facing a very hostile panel
of questioning from republicans
here's lindsey graham maybe one of the
most unhinged
brown-nosing trump sycophants trying to
play prosecutor
and he doesn't like sally yates's
answers so he keeps interrupting and
senator patrick leahy tells him hey
senator graham
just because sally yates is a woman
doesn't mean you have to keep it
interrupting her which is hilarious and
it kind of threw lindsey graham off for
a moment take a look
now let's talk about a january 5th
meeting
um was the vice president there
yes he must okay did he mention the
logan act
you know i don't remember the vice
president saying much of anything
so you don't remember him mentioning the
logan act
no i don't did anybody mention the logan
act
i have a vague memory uh director comey
mentioning the logan ad
okay what was he mentioning the logan
act about in what context
well that's i'm not sure if he mentioned
that
in the oval office meeting or in the
meeting
what do you think about that mr chairman
let her answer the question
just because it's a woman testifying
doesn't mean she has to be cut off yeah
thanks a lot
senator lee i really appreciate that
you're very constructive
so here's my question lindsey graham is
so horrible
and he does have a challenger in his
senate race i want to remind you that
jamie harrison is running against
lindsey graham
we could remove by we i mean the voters
of south carolina could remove lindsey
graham
that's an interesting race to follow and
maybe
get involved in continuing here's a
video of ted cruz
saying when did you first learn that the
obama administration was spying on the
trump campaign
yates says that never happened and ted
cruz
visibly flummoxed um miss yates
when did you first become aware that the
obama administration was surveilling
the donald trump campaign
the obama administration was not
surveilling the donald trump king
just a bizarre moment i mean this is
desperation
from these republicans and of course all
of this
is meant to distract from the disaster
after disaster after disaster that is
the current trump administration and ted
cruz
actually continued to propose things
that never happened
during his questioning of sally yates
and sally yates
continually had to continue putting him
in his place take a look at another
example
so if i's application is not
surveillance
the vice application was for carter page
who was a
former member of the trump campaign at
that point
so your testimony is that that the
investigation carter page had nothing to
do with the donald trump campaign
no i'm suggesting you ask me if we were
surveilling the campaign
you don't get it both ways is it the
campaign or not
senator i'm trying to give you what is
the accurate information here
carter page was a former member
of the trump campaign at the time that
the pfizer was initiated
and what was the reason for the fights
on carter page
there were a number of reasons first we
had gotten the information that i was
trying to point out here that the
russians had made the overture that they
wanted to be able to assist the trump
candidate said it had nothing to do with
the trump campaign
i said that he was not a member of the
trump campaign
at the time that we initiated now the
really sad thing is
that in republican circles they see
these same videos
and they see this as really brutal
questioning from ted cruz
that sally yates fell apart it's
semantic games it's
it's really a lesson actually in how the
right makes their arguments and it's a
lot of semantic games
and optics and i wish it didn't work but
it works
if you look at how republicans respond
to kaylee mcinanny's press briefings you
know kaylee comes out
and she scolds the media and then she
always has some
scripted walk out that is it like it
makes me
cringe when i see it but there are
people who love it
the vapid scripted walk-offs and the
attacks on media
many of us accurately see them for what
they are which are just completely
empty vapid meaningless optics but there
are republicans who love it and donald
trump jr will retweet it as
kaylee owns the media and that's exactly
the same thing that happens with
briefings or with testimony like this
where
the questions lindsey graham is asking
the questions ted cruz
is asking they are dumb leading
questions and sally yates has no choice
but to say that's not true that's not
true that's not true
but there is a contingent that says wow
she really fell apart let's look at just
a tiny bit more
cruz just keeps going here so when they
came to you asking to surveil
members of the trump campaign because of
conduct they allegedly did while members
of the trump campaign
what due diligence did you do did you
press back at all you already told
senator kennedy
you just trusted the fbi you didn't ask
about their sources you did i mean what
due diligence did you do
before signing off on
what we now have significant reason to
believe was a profound
politicization of law enforcement and
intelligence
senator there was a tremendous amount of
process back and forth
between the lawyers in the national
security division and the fbi
okay i asked what you did not not other
lawyers what due diligence did you do
you were the one signing off on it
and and with respect to whether the
facts were accurate
in this instance so did you inquire
whether it was opposition research
funded by the dnc or hillary clinton yes
i
did have a discussion about that so it
was
hours of this stuff hours and hours and
it's like trying to squeeze
water from a rock it's like there's a
lake
where all the water is and that's the
disaster after scandal after
embarrassment of the trump trump
administration
they ignore the lake where you could
just go and drink the water
and instead they focus on pricking up
picking up rocks
and trying to squeeze water out of them
and pretending that the lake doesn't
exist and we'd better thank them
for trying to squeeze water out of a
rock it's uh it's pathetic
it's going absolutely nowhere but if
trump wins
in november you can expect a lot more of
this
one of our sponsors is cuts clothing and
they're giving you
fifteen percent off of everything they
offer
when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's
c-u-t-s cuts clothing has
completely changed the game when it
comes to
solid color t-shirts obviously solid
color t-shirts
are an important staple in any wardrobe
which is all the more reason that you
should be wearing t-shirts that you
actually love
it really does impact your day-to-day
you've got your typical poorly made
t-shirt it's scratchy
it shrinks the neck becomes all floppy
the color fades it all starts to warp
over time
none of that happens with cuts clothing
as soon as i first put on a t-shirt
from cuts clothing i could immediately
tell the difference
between this and the other poorly made
shirts
that i've owned in the past and it's
really a very noticeable level of
quality and comfort and style
which i believe will change how you
think about t-shirts
go check out what they offer they also
have this new line of polo shirts
it's really more comfortable than any
polo shirt i've ever worn
cuts clothing will be a total game
changer when it comes to
t-shirts they're really the only t-shirt
worth buying
and now they've got the polos and you'll
get 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s